Well, I guess, I guess the thought,
I guess the thought I had was I've watched the least amount of anime this
year and I feel like a lot of people have lost you. Oh, sorry.
Last year, Hey,
I've watched the least amount of anime last year.
And I feel like a lot of people in the anime fandom have. Right.
And I feel like the community now is evolving from just being like,
there's a difference between now being an anime fan and the weave.
And we touched on this earlier,
but I realized this when hanging out with Connor,
how much of a normie Connor is compared to both?
Like, how's it feel?
How does it say you're a normie?
How does it feel for you hanging out with like people like us, I guess, or.
What do you mean? People like, we're a different breed, apparently. What's your,
why? Why do you think I'm a normie? First of all,
because you don't care about animals. My sweeter, I care about animals.
You, you care about dynamo, but there's only,
you only go so deep into the culture right.
Where you don't really get why food culture, you don't really get a lot of like,
Vici. Yeah. No, come on.
Well, tubing part of the culture, I think it is. Yeah. I mean, it, it grew up,
he grew out of the anime culture, right?
I mean, you know, you gotta kind of have a,
like an appreciation for anime in order to watch anime girls streaming.
Uh, I, I mean, I guess, I don't know. I mean, how deep,
how deep do you say your anime fandom goes?
That's a weird question to frame me maybe a scale or something that you can
judge me by a five, 10.
One is like.
One is like, you know, I watch a tackle on time to my hero academia.
Like just like just getting started all. And 10 is like,
I look at an anime and I know exactly who the Ganga artists for this is.
That. What are you on that scale? Where would you put yourself? Actually,
then this one might help me. I would put myself as a seven or nine,
probably. Like, I probably would've been like a five,
but now it's pretty like a full free, honestly,
but it's pretty cut and put it gone down to a three. And a recently has,
has like yours has.
Do you, do you feel like you've become less of an anime fan,
like more recently and have you like fallen out with the culture ever since you
moved here?
I guess, I guess because.
I mean, it's not like you don't watch anime, right? Like you still keep up.
Like.
I love our attacker cult show. I love like the community in general, but, um,
I think just when you get so deep into it, if we start like in the community,
I just started like,
not enjoy the community when it got into a point where I was getting really
deep. And everyone's like your name, your favorite Kiana Meda. And I was like,
what? I like the show and the story. I'm going to care about that.
Like, you know, we can argue that God and I probably at that point too,
but if someone came up to me and said, name your favorite Kiana mate,
I'll be like.
No, I think there was just a lot of like, at least when I was,
I don't know if it's still going on. I mean, you guys can tell me,
but then when I was getting,
trying to get really deep into it and I really wanted to learn more about it,
it got very like gatekeeping at a point. Yeah.
It definitely it's being like that. It's been like.
That for awhile.
I just started to like, not really enjoy it. And then I realized,
I think I just enjoy, I enjoy these shows way more when I'm just casual.
I mean, I just kinda to,
I just kinda learned to appreciate it more and kind of get deeper into it
without really interacting with the community around it. I'd say. Yeah. Well,
I guess.
I think me included when I get into something,
the one thing that I will always do is just like, look at the community for it.
All right. What's the norms. What,
what should I get into what's everyone saying like the best thing,
because that's a way of like guiding your, like,
it's like a tailored experience of like what everyone thinks of the best way of
enjoying something.
Cause, cause I feel like you don't really follow seasonal anime anymore. Right?
You just kind of wait to see what everyone's talking about and what's worth
watching. Like how would you decide what animated, what?
But I think that's because like the seasonal experience of viewing animates kind
of like died almost like, I don't think so.
I don't think people nearly talk about seasonal anime in a week by week way.
Like they used to.
I disagree.
I just think it's because last year was like so dry for seasonal anime, um,
that there was just nothing for people to talk.
It was just a lot of mid shows last year.
I just feel like now,
especially with like Netflix coming and releasing the episodes in,
like everyone is like, it's not, you know,
did you watch the latest episode of be stars? Did you watch the stars?
Like, you know, that's like one out of every hundred animals.
I feel like everyone asks that now. It's not.
Did you watch the newest episode itself? It's D.
Well, I would say like, Oh, you watch, like, people are still asking.
Are you watching the newest episode of attack on Titan?
Are you watching attack on Titan? Are you watching the newest episode?
Literally every stream I do. There's always
[inaudible]. It's like, have you watched this item app?
And it's different than talking, talking. There's not a ton of time.
Like any seasonal enemy? No,
normally I never get seasonal and I have to ask him, you know,
I get that all the time. No one gives a. If I was watching, like, or I'm on,
what is that? Was it all right? What's it called? What's it
[inaudible] generic feels good. Anyway, that's an eight season, you know? Like,
are you watching that? No one asks me, it. I'm gonna ask him that.
If I'm watching that, no one asks me for watch decadence. You know what I mean?
Like no one gives a because there's so many enemies that are so mid now
somebody's.
Coming out. I tried watching there's so.
Many animals that are coming out. That the only ones people I seem to have that,
cause it used to be again,
when there's a lot less animate as well that everyone could kind of ask,
are you watching these shows? Are you watching it weekly?
And now it's just so many. And we have so many like good shows,
but like we only really, I find in my experience at general,
Twitter only really asked if you're watching a show weekly now or keeps up with
the hype if it's a big event like that.
Right, right. Right. Because I feel it was missing last year.
Was that big event. Cause last year we had something like the demon Slayer,
that demon slate episode that really like.
And then I never saw like week by week place by demon slammed people by week.
I was like, yo demon epididymus lamps are 17.
Boys will be all saying what we we'll say on Twitter. You know?
Don't like any of that, it was just an episode. 19 was amazing. It gave the,
both of my children, Jesus Christ, his re reborn, like that's what happened.
Right. And that was it. Like,
there wasn't anything else other than like demon Slayer. Good. Right.
That was there. I feel like, do you not think that's kind of like gut check?
It's shifted a little. I I'm. I am I seeing, I think.
Maybe it's just shifted just because you've kind of shifted away from it.
Cause I've also shifted away from it too.
And I've definitely noticed like the lack of,
I do feel like that's so many people, cause I know so many people now who,
like they say, they're anime fans a hundred percent. And the, the,
the, all they do is read manga what? Vici tubers and play Gacha games. Wow.
I mean this photo
[inaudible] I never seen him talking about episode three of this.
It's always chapter this of this Munger.
Cause everyone knows that they're released at this point.
And then everyone keeps up with it on Twitter. But I never see it for,
for anime. No one does anime episode reviews anymore.
Except for like big shows or [inaudible] everyone does Monga chapters,
things still that's so popular. I mean, I genuinely think it shifted.
I don't think I'm the weird one here. I can't see the truth. What's happening.
I disagree with like, no one does episode reviews anymore.
Cause there's still like,
there's still like a big group of YouTubers who still do it.
Oh really? You watch episode reviewers name. Every episode of your writing
[inaudible] will be taken down and chippy will still be making reviews.
I don't know who like, come on. That doesn't count, man.
Well, no, that's literally, that's the only one that matters in my opinion,
I guess. I mean, I,
I feel like that kind of mirrors the culture now because
I feel like definitely at being an animated YouTuber last year was hard.
Um, anime contents last year was like for, from my perspective,
animate content on YouTube just didn't do as well.
There's no one was watching any anime videos around anime culture.
Like what you guys were doing. You guys, you fight,
you guys killed it last year, in my opinion.
And I feel like that's because nobody,
nobody like people care less about individual shows now.
And people just more care about culture.
I think the last time I did a show or a video on a show that was like seasonal
and ongoing was promise Neverland. And that was like, what? Two years ago?
Three years ago. It.
Banana fish amazing.
It was like two, three years ago. Right. And it's like, since then,
it's just like every season comes around and I do, what will I be watching?
And then I look at the list and I was like.
Like Joey used to change the tile that I lied to you for 20 minutes
while I'm looking at the comments of finally called you out of their
lighters.
Yeah, of course. No, th that, that series now is just a quick,
easy way of being like, Oh, let's see what Joey thinks about this.
We know he's not going to watch it,
but at least we'll know what he feels about it. But for me,
seasonal anime has just become this glorified Mongo recommendation system.
Where if, if, if, if I find.
A series like this, it's so good.
This is what like shopping is to Amazon.
I go to the store to go and buy it on Amazon.